World Cup fans are passionate and
thirsty especially in victory the German
beer industry to have a banner year they
need two assists one they need good
summer weather and two they need the
national team to go deep into the
tournament so that beer gardens like
this one stay open late and everyone
drinks when germany scores countrywide
sales have been declining since 1976
back then the average German drink north
of a hundred and fifty litres a pint of
brew 300 days a year in 2013 that had
fallen to a hundred and six liters a
year just 212 nights of light boozing so
the brow arise have an economic
incentive to root for the home team some
of Germany's biggest like kelana and
berlina Kendall may need to work their
brew masters over time if Germany does
well we have breweries who report that
they have sold 1 million litres more
beer than on a normal day there's
another way to measure beer in take out
the Berlin Water Works has its own
technical analysis halftime flushers
when germany played ghana water lose
almost tripled during the break and then
a return to the norm after the match so
no late night pardon the game was a draw
Hunt's nickos Bloomberg